Put your seatbelt on
and we're going to help him.
No, Joel!
Welcome back, Everyone is Charlie.
This will be my thought.
Will last of us. Episode four Video.
There are a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references.
They introduced a bunch of big characters
from the games
and some new characters
that weren't on the game.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
We're doing a giveaway
for HBO Max Subscriptions
all yet through Enter is be a subscriber
and just post your favorite moments
from the episode in the comments.
Careful for spoilers on the episode
if you haven't seen it yet.
We'll start at the beginning. Work
our way through shot by shot.
Talk to you about Easter eggs and WTF
moments, starting with the episode title
Please Hold My Hand,
which is a reference to the Hank Williams
song the Ellie finds in Bill stuff
and they play during the car trip.
The scene is taken directly from the video
game, as are many of the scenes
in their lines of dialog
during the episode.
Dear, let's make you all nostalgic.
You know, that is actually before my time.
That is winter,
though. This make you almost allergic
is actually before my time.
Right? It's winter though.
But they did move around a few things
during the episode from when they happened
during the game.
The title Please Hold My Hand are actually
lyrics taken from the song
the actual song's name is Alone
in For Sake Second,
and it's meant to be a metaphor
for everything that's happening
during the series, everything
that's happened to their characters.
The lyrics of the song Talk about pastures
were green, the meadows were gold.
But her love, like the leaves have now
withered and gone.
A metaphor for the downfall of humanity,
the world decaying now metaphorically.
It also refers to John
Ellis previous relationships
like Dawn Tess because she's gone now.
Elliot's previous relationship with Riley,
who is also gone now.
There are a couple of big references
to Riley in this episode
that I'll mention
when we get to those parts of the episode.
We got a little bit
more of Ellie's back story,
but like she's slowly teasing it out,
like they're slowly opening up
to each other
about each of their histories.
The lyrics of the song
are also a metaphor
about their developing relationship, too.
If you hear me, please, Lord,
hold my hand like Joe taking care of Ellie
the way
he would take care of his daughter.
But both of them relying on each other
for help like Ellie, literally
helps him in the episode.
And Joe also needs
a bit of emotional help, so to speak,
like they both start
emotionally supporting each other.
In reality, he needs her
just as much as she needs him.
They haven't been changing the opening
theme titles as far as I can tell.
I've already talked a little bit
about the imagery
during them in my previous episode videos.
The actual opening scene
is of Ellie in the gas Stop fantasizing,
practicing with Billy's gun
that she took pretending to be a badass.
She's in for a rude awakening, having
to kill another person in cold blood.
Not just simple infected or killing
someone is immediate threat
That they might kill her,
even though she does hint to Joel
that she's killed someone before it.
That's a reference to Riley.
You can tell that she's still trying
to toughen up and learn how to handle
the emotional weight
of what comes with using a gun.
We start to see more of their relationship
developing with Ellie's book of puns
during the episode.
They're all very much in the tone of dad
humor level jokes, really dumb dad humor,
even though at first he's
still very reluctant to get close to her,
she keeps wearing down his emotional
defenses through the episode with the puns
and all the trauma that they experience
with the hunters as well
until the end of the episode,
when he genuinely laughs
with her at the points like a dad would.
The actual book that she's holding,
Livingston's book of puns
is directly from the games
It's in The Last of US Left Behind.
Ellie and Riley found the book,
no pun Intended to toast
while they were at the amusement park.
And during their car trip in the game.
She also reads in the puns in the book
like she does here in the episode.
Their relationship is very complicated.
It's not simply a little girl
idolizing a new father figure.
When she starts to learn more about Joel's
backstory, she learns how complicated
he is about the terrible things
that he's done in his past.
One of the big themes of The Last of US,
the games in the show, is forgiveness
in general.
Like Joel is seeking forgiveness,
redemption in what he's doing with Ellie.
But you get a better sense
for their dynamic together.
They start to feel more like a father
daughter pair
as she begins to make fun of them for not
knowing how a siphon works,
like not knowing the science behind it.
Also messing with him in the car
in a playful way.
The whole gas station scene, the overnight
camping scene, are not from the games.
In the games.
They just simply drive away
after Bill gives them the car,
stopping at the roadblock
before they encounter the hunters.
The other big change is that the hunters
they encounter were in Pittsburgh,
not in Kansas City like on the show.
But for the most part,
all the moments that they have in the car,
the dialog are taken
directly from the game.
When Joel is explaining why all the damage
cars are on the road look like that.
He talks about the military's
tanks plowing the roads.
Clean house.
You'll see one of the tanks
soon is a reference to a short
while later in the episode down the road
where they pass
a bunch of abandoned military vehicles.
And Joel talks about how the military
was designed to fight the wrong enemy
because the military was designed to fight
other countries, and the real enemy
was the fungus in
the military were relatively ineffective
against it, which is why you see
all the abandoned vehicles on the road,
see how much use they were in fighting
the fungus, the tape of Hank Williams
that Ellie pulls out of the back seat
and their dialog directly from the game.
But the Hank Williams song
didn't start playing in the game
until they got stopped by the hunters,
as opposed to the show
where they listen to it
right at the beginning here.
Joel Having to explain who Hank Williams
is is because
Ellie has absolutely no idea, because
she was born after the apocalypse started.
She just thinks of Joel as another old
because he seems like an old man to her,
really.
He's in his fifties.
In the song itself was written by Hank
Williams in 1948, long before
Joel was born.
They also use
this particular Hank Williams song
in a bunch of the trailers for the series.
The Dirty magazine
that Ellie finds in Bill's
backseat is also right out of the games.
It's the exact same version
of the magazines,
like a fictional magazine
they created for the game
light on the reading.
But it's got some interesting photos
that Ellie, that ain't for kids.
So as is their dialog, when she starts
messing with him and he freaks out
not knowing how to answer her.
When she asks why the pages are stuck
together,
he's not going to touch that
with a ten foot pole.
As Joel explains.
The reason why the livestock are alive
here in the Midwest
is because it's too remote
for the infected to live here.
Because of the way
the fungus mutated, it tends to congregate
around the population centers,
and because of that, the real danger
out here in this part of the country
isn't the fungus, it's
the other people, rogue bands
living outside the quarantine zone there,
many of them of different sizes,
all meant to foreshadow their encounter
with the hunters, like terrible people
who would do things far worse
than just trying to steal their stuff.
And it's a long trip
after they make it to Kansas City.
So, like, it's just the beginning of them
running into really dangerous
small groups on the way.
The reason why Joel is so wary of them
and just during the episode in general,
especially when they get inside
Kansas City, as he tells Ellie, is
because he used to be one of the hunters
when he was first traveling
from Austin to the Boston
quarantine zone with his brother in tests.
That's what he and Tess met earlier
when they said
that they weren't good people
because all the messed up stuff
you see the hunters doing in the episode,
they did that too, to survive.
Although Joel does say
that he was only with the hunters
because his brother joined them and
he wanted to keep an eye on his brother.
So, yes, he did do terrible things
and killed people in cold blood.
Like later in the episode when he asks
him, Did you kill people in cold blood?
He doesn't answer.
Obviously, the answer was meant to be yes,
like she took the meaning from his
silence to be yes.
But they want to make
it feel more complex.
Like he wasn't doing that.
He wasn't being violent
because he wanted to for violence sake.
He was doing it just because he was trying
to protect his brother.
During the early leg of their drive here,
the bridge that they pass over
isn't meant to be the bridge
from Pittsburgh in the game,
but it is a reference
to that bridge in the game.
Their escape from Pittsburgh is a bridge
which is heavily guarded by the hunters.
They pass an RB sign paying off bills.
Arby's Joke from Episode three
When he first met Frank in this trap,
Arby's,
the brand in real life got in on the joke
after the episode aired, too,
with their own social media posts.
Every time I see Arby's jokes,
all I can think of is that Simpsons joke.
I'm so hungry I could eat it at Arby's.
The reason Joel
pulls the car into the woods and won't let
Ellie have a fire is to prevent
those other potential people from finding
them, killing them, eating them, doing
all kinds of terrible things to them.
They bond over their enjoyment of Hank
Williams and Chef Boyardee ravioli.
Like he slowly starts to agree with her
and enjoy things that she does,
which is part of their arc in the episode.
The puns them getting closer.
By the end of the episode, you also start
to get a sense for Joel's sense of humor.
Like he does have a sense of humor,
even though he is in a very jokey
type of person when he makes fun of Bill
by saying that the nice smelling sleeping
bag must have been Franks
and him knowing the answer to the pun.
Now he doesn't know
because he read the book.
It's just because it's really dumb
and easy to figure out.
But while this is all going
on, he's still kind of
having PTSD flashbacks to his daughter.
Like he's
starting to feel that same energy,
the same vibe that he felt
when he was with his daughter.
That's why he's so reluctant
to get close to Ellie, even at this point.
He doesn't want to emotionally
open himself up to another person yet
just because he assumes
the worst is going to happen.
But through the episode,
she slowly begins to wear him down
and they start to open up to each other.
The next morning, when she starts
complaining about the smell of coffee.
That's also taken from a conversation
of the game that happens later
when they're inside an abandoned
coffee shop in Pittsburgh on the run
from the Hunters.
But the dialog, the jokes are meant to be
similar from the one in the game.
Oh, this place stinks.
Words. I'll run.
Did you go to coffee shops a lot?
I did all the time.
And what would you get? Just.
Just coffee.
When he slurps
the coffee to mess with her.
That's also him
showing his own sense of humor.
Again, just the dad humor that he has.
Joel begins explaining his brother Tommy,
and their relative back story.
Tommy is the younger brother who Joel has
felt responsible for their entire life.
And even though they disagree,
like Joel disapproved of him
joining
all these different groups over his life
the military, the hunters,
then the fireflies,
then whatever is going on with him
now that he's trying to figure out
he still feels responsible for him,
wants to protect him because of his belief
that family is the most important thing
in the apocalypse.
He and Test weren't married
or anything like that,
but they were together as a couple
for so long that he considered her family.
Whereas Ellie, as he says
right here in the episode,
at least at this
early point, is not family.
She still just obligation in his eyes,
but slowly that's beginning to change.
What happened to Tommy is that after
the initial fungus spread in 2003,
Tommy joined the group of hunters
that were heading to Boston.
Joel joined with him
to keep an eye on him.
Along the way, he met Tess,
and while that was happening
on their journey to Boston,
they did all these crazy things
that you see the hunters do
in the episode, trapping people, killing
innocent people, stealing their stuff
just to survive all the dark things
that he's still having trouble
telling Ellie about.
Like, yeah, I definitely did
kill a whole bunch of innocent people.
But the whole idea
is that during that time,
Joel didn't enjoy what they were doing.
Like he didn't relish
in hurting innocent people,
and he left the first chance
he got with Tess.
While that was happening,
Tommy found Marlene, and she won him over
to the Fireflies in their quote
unquote grand quest to save the world.
As Joel talks about it,
which he thinks is completely misguided,
The Fireflies actual plan
is to also overthrow the federal military
and install a civilian government
more akin to what society used to be like
before the apocalypse,
thinking they do a much better job
of administrating life in the apocalypse
and also at the same time
developing a vaccine.
That's really
where the quote unquote, save
the world comes from and where
Ellie gets involved in the story.
But eventually
Tommy grows disillusioned with them.
It's implied that he was also having to do
terrible things while he was with them
because the whole idea
is that the fireflies,
even though they seem
like a really good group, do things
that are just as bad as Phaedra
and as the Hunters.
Morally speaking,
pretty much everyone on the show are just
shades of gray
like no one is truly good or truly evil.
Eventually, Tommy leaves the fireflies,
and that's where Joel lost
contact with him and why he's going to
Wyoming to find out what happened to him.
His whole conversation with Ellie
about what really matters in life,
why it's important to continue living
is also really important
for their whole arc in the series.
Just in general.
More specifically, it foreshadows
some of the controversial decisions
that Joel will make regarding
Ellie towards the end of the first game.
It will probably be the end of season one,
like I believe they're meant to cover
all the first game during season one,
when he eventually does start to think of
her as family, as his surrogate daughter.
Like in this conversation,
he's loving Ellie.
No, in no uncertain terms,
family is the most important thing,
more important
than anything more important
than the rest of the human race.
So remember that
it's like the core of his being.
It informs every decision
that he makes, even all the terrible stuff
he was forced to do while he was still
with the hunters a long time ago.
He was doing it in the name
of keeping his family Tommy, safe.
Right now, Ellie,
who just barely experienced all this,
she's so young, is looking for a reason
to continue.
Like, what is the point of living
if it's going to be like this?
And Joel's just telling him,
you continue because of family.
I'm sure there's a fast
and Furious meme in here somewhere.
Like Joel will eventually say
the word family almost as many times
as Vin Diesel says the word family
when they encounter the roadblock.
All this is generally
the same as the game.
But they made the big change from
Pittsburgh to Kansas City in the episode.
The hunters are meant to be
a rogue faction in the game,
like the fireflies, who seek to establish
their own dominance over Phaedra.
The hunters
also want to get rid of Phaedra as well,
but they have their own idea
of what order is in the apocalypse.
Within the context of the story,
the hunters overthrew
the federal authority in Kansas City,
in Pittsburgh, in the game,
and just continued to rule the city
with an iron fist,
killing outsiders
that would come along for their supplies.
They set up this massive roadblock
here at the tunnel as an elaborate trap,
forcing outsiders
to enter the city where it be easier
to kill them and take their stuff.
They had these roadblocks in all
the entrances and exits to the city.
That's why when they're entering the city,
the camera pans across that burned
pile of skeletons.
Those are bodies of regular people
not infected that the hunters
had previously killed,
like they tried to do to Joel in a year,
the scene of the hunter
pretending to be hurt
to get them out of the car is right
out of the game.
The reason why Joel knows immediately
there's that trap is because he was
one of them and would have done
the exact same thing in this situation.
Going to help him?
Put your seatbelt on, Ellie,
what about the guy?
He ain't even hurt.
They're only a couple of hunters
that they deal with at this trap here.
But they have traps
like this all over the city.
Their group is relatively large.
It's meant to show you how they control
all access in and out of the city.
They're all mission here is to escape
the city.
They're going to have to do this
again, like escape through
another group of hunters to get out.
This whole encounter here
is meant to be more about Ellie, though.
Saving Joel and using Bill's gun
in proving to Joel
that she herself could do it
once she was capable of being useful
and who she also deserved to have a gun.
She almost enjoys this moment here, too,
pulling the trigger.
But that's
when the hunters back was turned,
when she didn't have to face him directly.
You can see her moment of hesitation
when he turns around and starts
to sob story
to get her to stop. When she talked
about having to kill someone
before like this isn't her first time.
That time was also very different
from what's happening here.
It was still super traumatic,
but she absolutely had to do it.
It was sort of a fight
or flight kind of thing.
This time, she's in
no immediate danger. It's
more her killing someone in cold blood,
which she talks to Joel about later.
She isn't able to kill someone in cold
blood yet.
That's also a big part of her art, too,
like the way that she just deals
with surviving in the apocalypse.
Like the terrible things
that you have to do in order to survive.
Joel on the other hand,
obviously, no problem killing people
for any reason, even though in this case
it's totally warranted like that.
Hunter definitely would have either
informed on them
or continued to try and kill Joel
and Ellie after the fact.
The reason that he uses
the Hunter's knife to finish
the job is just pure resource management.
As Bill said in episode three, it's
all about resource management
in the apocalypse.
Conserve your bullets.
Also, knives make way less noise
and they really want to avoid
alerting more hunters
when they're escaping
to the other building.
The Humvee that passes by is one
the hunters stole
from the federal authority
during the uprising.
The other cars,
they just scavenge from what
they could put together across the city
and other supplies that they've stolen
from unsuspecting travelers.
We meet Melanie Lynskey,
Kathleen character.
She's not from the game.
She's like a brand new character
for the show.
She's meant to be one of the co-leaders
of the hunters here in Kansas City.
With Perry.
Their scene
basically gives you the backstory
what happened in Kansas City
and how the Hunters overthrew Fedora
because like Boston, in other cities,
Phaedra were doing terrible things,
like it was just generally
a terrible existence for everyone
while they were still under
federal authority.
It sounds like the federal military
captured her brother and tortured him
because of something that he was doing.
And she's actor Henry and Sam
because Henry gave up the location
of her brother to Phaedra, Henry and Sam,
huge characters from the games.
They changed their story a little.
I'll talk about that
when we get to their part of the episode.
On the show, though,
the ideas that Phaedra
would have threatened Sam's life
and Henry's whole thing,
like his whole reason for existence.
As Joel says, protecting his brother Tommy
is to protect Sam, his younger brother.
So he would have had no problem giving up
Kathleen's brother
to protect his little brother.
And in the wake of her brother's death,
Kathleen is just looking
for revenge on Henry
and is going to crazy lengths to get it.
One of the reasons why
I think they added her in
the show is just to build out the Hunter
storyline like they did this whole side
storyline where they change
Henry and Sam's backstory
just so that more is going on during this
big Kansas City Hunters encounter
in the game, it was a little bit simpler,
but it was the same basic premise
whole bunch of hunters, inner city,
they have to make it through the city.
They also want to use.
Kathleen is a more complicated
kind of antagonist.
She's somewhat justified in wanting
revenge for her brother, but what she does
goes so over the line
she becomes a villain.
So it's not so much like a Negan
Walking Dead situation where he just loves
power for power's sake.
That's why later, when she and Perry
find one of Henry in Sam's hiding spot,
she pauses for a second.
When she sees all of Sam's drawings,
she wavers a little
because he's just a little kid,
and in the moment she kind of understands
the complexity of what Henry did.
Like, Oh, he wanted to protect his family.
Like I care about my family.
Only for a second, though.
Then she snaps back to cold, hard revenge.
The hunters
generally are meant to be a much darker
mirror to the fireflies as well.
Like the fireflies still do bad things.
Like I said, but they're saints
compared to the hunters generally.
You're smart to understand
why Kathleen is doing this,
where she's coming from,
but it's also meant to be terrible.
She's still meant to have gone
a little bit nuts.
During her conversation with the doctor,
we learned
she was originally from Kansas City
before the fungus.
He was her family doctor
who delivered her in a local hospital
and showing you how cold she's gotten
when she doesn't hesitate to kill him
after he's no longer of immediate use her,
even though it's not like doctors
are falling off of trees
in the apocalypse,
probably want to keep
as many of those around as you can.
When she's spitballing on Joel and Ellie,
assuming that they're mercenaries
that Henry and Sam hired,
it sounds like she almost believes that.
I don't think she's totally lying here.
Like she's exaggerating a little bit
and using that as an excuse to ratchet up
their tactics around the city.
When we go back to join
Ellie hiding in a nearby business
on the newspaper
outside, there's an article about hiding.
There's articles on the other newspapers
all over the inside about the immediate
aftermath of that night in 2003,
when the military rolled out
around the country to deal with the fungus
for the first time.
One of the other differences
from the game, too,
during this part of the story,
originally they were trying
to get across the bridge
in Pittsburgh to escape the city.
This time on the show,
the hunters are still guarding
all the exits
from the city on the other side.
But it's not the bridge,
the scene of Joel and Ellie bonding,
where he teaches her
how to use the gun properly.
Also right out of the game.
It just happens
in a slightly different place in the game.
She starts to reveal her backstory
a little more
when she says this wasn't her first time
killing someone.
That's Riley she's talking about.
We'll see more of that in future episodes.
But right now, she's still too
traumatized by what happened with Riley
to completely talk about it.
It's the same thing with Joel.
Like they're slowly
opening up to each other
about their histories,
continuing to bond as father and daughter.
You notice Sam's drawings on the walls
depict their history.
Living in Kansas City
under the federal authority
like he has drawings of his brother Henry,
fighting federal soldiers
and blowing up their gear, depictions
of them as superhero shows like the one
she picks up with them
wearing the superhero suits,
which Sam is wearing
at the end of the episode,
like the mask he's wearing
when he has begun on Joel.
When they go to the basement and comment
on the fungus that shifting beneath the
cabin, this isn't from the game either.
I think what they've done
is they taken the big blue order encounter
from Bill's in the game earlier
and just set up a version of that here.
And the thing shifting beneath the floor
that Kathleen says
that they'll worry about later
might be the show's version of a blotter
because it would just have to be way
bigger and more powerful than a clicker
in order to make the floor shift like this
an early prediction
This creature will get out
and go on a rampage
by the climax of either
next week's episode
or just as
they're about to escape the city
like they start fighting the hunters,
things get really nuts.
And then this giant creature escapes.
I don't know how many episodes
we're supposed to be in Kansas City for.
Maybe just one more episode,
maybe two more
Joe and Ellie hiding in the other building
and encountering Henry.
And Sam is also a slightly different
version of what happens in the game.
In the game,
it was just a normal apartment building
and they accidentally ran into them
while they were trying to run away.
In the episode.
It's Henry and Sam that run into them
while they're sleeping.
It's implied that they had also been there
in that same building, hiding,
and just heard them enter in a waited
until they fell asleep
to sneak past the broken glass.
But just like in the game,
Sam was the one holding the gun on.
Joel.
In the whole ending of the episode
here is huge,
not just because of the introduction
of Henry and Sam,
because they're huge characters
from the game.
It's a huge step forward in Joel
and Liz relationship, whereas before
he'd really shown
no signs in caring about her backstory
or what was going on inside her head
or anything like that,
him asking her about the thing
that she didn't
want to talk about in her past
killing a person.
Now he's actively interested
in learning about her past trauma.
This thing,
this person that she killed, that
she doesn't want to talk about,
and them sharing the laugh together
over more bad puns
until obviously we meet Henry and Sam.
Couple of differences here in the game.
There's no backstory with Kathleen's
brother or giving anyone up.
Henry and Sam were also from a different
town and just wound up in Pittsburgh.
Obviously different city than the TV show
where they were trying to escape,
just seeking shelter and then trying
to get through escaping the hunters.
The reason why
Henry wanted to escape the hunters
in the game is because they just generally
didn't like children, because they didn't
think they were useful.
And he was trying
to protect his little brother, Sam.
So they wanted to get through the blockade
that the hunters
had on the other side of the city.
Without getting into spoilers,
I'm expecting their storyline
to be very similar
to what it was in the game.
If you have played the game, please
don't post those spoilers in the comments.
The song during the ending credits
was also a version of Gary
Jules Mad World, which Ellie also plays
during The Last of US two.
Most of the songs that you see in the show
are songs that they used in the game,
or just original music from the game,
like the main theme song.
But next week might be the conclusion
of the Hunters storyline.
Maybe it'll go three episodes.
We'll see if you spotted any other Easter
eggs or references during the episode
that I didn't mention in the video.
Right them below in the comments.
My Last of US Episode
five Trailer video will post Next
they will be posting episode
five on Friday because of the Super Bowl
a couple days early, so my episode review
will post right after that
and I will be doing trailer videos
for all the big Super Bowl trailers.
Everyone click here for my Last of US
Episode five Video.
Edit the link As soon as I post
that and click here to watch Kit Harington
talk about his Game of Thrones
Jon Snow's sequel series.
Thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and I'll see you guys
in the next one.